[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce soir on revient sur les nouvelles
déclarations de la chanteuse Angèle à
l'affiche du dernier film Astérix et
Obélix
après avoir été en couple avec une
youtubeuse et avoir confirmé être autant
attiré par les hommes que par les femmes
la chanteuse Angèle qui a fait son
coming out la chanteuse belge vient de
faire de nouvelles révélations dans
le de 27 ans ont couverture du mensuel
s'est livré comme rarement sur sa vie
sentimentale et a fait cette déclaration
choc je suis en phase avec l'idée du
polyamour alors Angèle révèle avoir
adopté le principe du polyamour et vous
pourriez vous être en couple libre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je suis en couple exactement elle a dit
qu'elle était en phase avec l'idée
exactement quand on est artiste et qu'on
a la chance d'avoir un peu de lumière
c'est bien je trouve d'avoir des idéaux
des de pouvoir exprimer le fait que tout
le monde a le droit d'être libre oui on
peut être un peu de gens ça peut arriver
dans la vie
évoqué oui moi je suis à 100% pour le
couple libre mais que d'un côté
et là ça me rassure parce que je pensais
qu'avant j'étais un en fait je
suis juste un polyamoureux dans l'air du
temps c'est
bon
les personnes t'as demandé
tu peux pas non tu peux pas t'amuser
je reviens je vais voir la deuxième et à
la deuxième guerre je reviens
que personne ne souffre voilà
[Applaudissements]
une question ça veut dire Raymond que tu
es donc d'accord pour que tes
différentes compagnes aille aussi voyant
voilà je souffre moi de me dire
elle ne souffre pas toi pourquoi vous
compliquer
tout le monde et voilà
la libido quand même
fini un moment ou un autre par chercher
c'est tout le temps les mêmes caresses
les mêmes trucs
là ce soir
[Applaudissements]
on est on est pas bien on est pas on est
passé cure secure là gilbertez
j'ai eu un texto il y a un instant il me
dit oui moi je suppose je regardais
Fatou
non moi je suis pour l'idée pour moi
mais je trouve que c'est génial en plus
qu'elle en parle qu'elle dise qu'elle
est bisexuelle de toi là moi non non je
sais pas pour ça moi avec Guillaume avec
Guillaume ah ça c'est pas bête comme il
est ouais
honnêtement si j'avais pu m'installer
dans un trouble ça aurait été avec
Guillaume et qui le troisième
à quatre aussi par exemple enfin
tu parles de qui en 4e
[Rires]
c'est toi c'est toi
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas du tout pour le polyam en fait
que la personne qui est avec toi
ailleurs je vais lui casser la gueule
dans la bouche
Delphine alors moi sur le principe
j'aime bien pour les autres
effectivement pas pour moi
parce que je pense qu'on peut être
effectivement amoureux de plusieurs
personnes en même temps voilà de deux en
même temps mais par contre
et on peut pas aimer à partir du moment
où on aime quand on a passé le cap
d'aimer avec tout ce que ça comporte et
que ça signifie bah après non c'est
exclusif
je crois que c'est ça les polyamoureux
estiment qu'ils peuvent aimer plusieurs
personnes en même temps d'un même niveau
moi
déjà concentre-toi
[Rires]
je sais pas pourquoi
deux fois écoute en tout cas
alors moi je suis pas du tout
moi je suis un peu comme moi
ouais ouais j'aime pas et puis voilà
après Jean-Marie ce qu'il a dit ça m'a
ben oui c'était choqué un petit peu mais
moi je crois que tu es un gros menteur
[Applaudissements]
je sais que les problèmes auditif
vous l'avez toujours dit que par exemple
si votre compagne
on ne supportez maintenant exactement
[Rires]
est-ce que vous pensez ce que ce que
disent les gens qui font du polyamour
qu'on peut aimer plusieurs personnes à
égalité
c'est difficile
[Rires]
[Musique]